hey you guys doing another flickers of
fear review
uh if you'll notice i have the chair
here but mothman isn't in it he decided
he was gonna hang back there upon the
thing
it's just i can't i try to be like in
the middle of the frame because you know
normally like tom is here
but i don't know i'm just not used to
like sitting over there where the
middle of the frame is so it's just like
i'm gonna do this and i'm just gonna
like put [ __ ] over here like so
so it'll be like all like [ __ ]
balanced or whatever so you know sorry
if that's weird but so as i mentioned on
my
review of the invitation uh one thing
that i wanted to do
this month uh you know to a small degree
was i wanted to
talk about some movies that i had seen
previously
and really really liked and in a lot of
cases had uh written long blog posts
about when i back when i originally saw
them
and i wanted to watch them again and
review them for this
show because i liked them so much the
first time
so basically that's what we're doing
again today like i said last time i did
the invitation and this time i'm doing
another movie from 2015
which actually i think i saw this one
into in summer of 2017 also around the
same time that i watched the invitation
because i was watching a lot of
newer horror movies around that time
period that had come out in the previous
five years or so
and this is called they look like people
this is not
okay i'm gonna call this this is a
psychological horror film
but i've seen it like not called a
horror film i would argue with that
at the same time i can kind of see where
people are coming from too because it's
not really a traditional horror film in
any sense of the word
but it should be noted though that this
movie
is creepy as [ __ ] like
some like just the whole atmosphere of
it is like creepy as [ __ ]
but it's also one of the most
human horror movies i think i've ever
seen if that makes any sense
in the sense that it has such
empathy for its characters
that this is legitimately one of the
only horror movies that i think i've
ever
watched that actually like made me kind
of tear up at the end much like train to
busan or something like that which is
another one i think i said that about
but this one the ending of this one is
just so
uplifting that it just kind of like
it gave me feels i'm just gonna say that
right now
because it's in and the reason that it
does is because the character work in
this
is just so so effective and so so
natural
and you really get to know these
characters these two guys and like you
really get a sense of the parameters of
like the friendship that they share
which is kind of
like at the heart of this movie other
than all of like the creepy [ __ ] going
on
and i think that's what really kind of
makes this one a cut above
now as with most horror movies this
isn't going to be for everybody some
people might think it's oh it's too slow
or nothing happens or it's too ambiguous
or blah blah
but i don't know it's just i really
really enjoyed this one and like i said
this is another one that i'm really
really glad that i
got to watch again a second time because
i've liked it just as much if not more
uh the second time is the first time i
saw it back in 2017.
now this one this movie i know i tried
not to like spoil
too much about the invitation like about
the end and stuff but this one i think i
probably will because
i really really love the ending of this
and i really wanted to talk about it a
little bit
and um so it's gonna be really really
hard to
talk about it without spoiling that
because it's kind of like the crux of
the whole entire
like theme of the movie so if you want
to watch this movie
and you don't want anything spoiled
because again this is one of the movies
that's
better if you don't really know anything
about it going in
so basically just go watch it and then
come back and watch this because i am
going to spoil the ending and
you know various uh plot points and
things it's actually it was on netflix
which is where i watched it back in
2017. i'm not sure if it's on there
anymore
but um it's on 2b for free uh and i
believe it's also on amazon prime if you
have amazon prime i think you can watch
it for free on there
as well i'm not entirely sure because i
watched it again on tubey but uh you
know so go check it out if you're really
really into like creepy
uh low-key uh psychological kind of
horror it's like a micro
micro budget but i don't think that
impedes it in any way
shape or form this is actually the
entire project of perry blackshear uh he
wrote it edited it directed it uh shot
it he was a cinematographer everything
so
this is very much and i mean this in the
best way possible this is very much uh
a passion project of perry blackshear
and his uh friends that were also in the
movie
and so it really has that organic like i
said this kind of natural you can tell
that these
the people in this uh movie are making
friends in real life or they hung out in
real life
because it comes across as just very
genuine on screen so like i said i
really really like these
just independent films that come out
just fantastic like this so
one of my easily one of my favorite
movies uh horror movies from 2015
uh and from the past 10 years also so
what we have
at the very beginning of this uh there's
a guy named
christian and he's kind of like he has
some kind of
high techy like media type job or
something like that they don't really
specify it doesn't really matter
but the implication as it goes on is
that
he was once kind of like a geek like in
high school or junior high or whatever
and he's still really really really
insecure but to sort of
compensate for that he's become
he started like working out so he got
like really muscular and everything
and then he starts listening to all
these kind of daily affirmations and
things like that like telling you are a
mountain you're this that in the other
and uh he's talking about at his
job he's like oh yeah you know i was
like i'm dominating and all this other
kind of stuff so he's really kind of
gone from like an insecure kind of dorky
kid
to really the the whole other end of the
spectrum but all of those insecurities
are still there
now he lives by himself in an apartment
in new york city
uh his fiancee has uh
recently left and in fact it is her
voice
that we hear like when he's listening to
these daily affirmations
uh he made her like record well he
didn't make her i guess when they were
together like she did it for him
but uh she recorded all these daily
affirmations and he's still listening to
them even though she has
subsequently left him so we have that
guy
now the other character we have is wyatt
now these two were friends back in
junior high high school something like
that they show like some pictures
they don't go a huge amount there's not
like a lot of you know exposition
but you pick things up from hints you
know what i mean like
hints of things they say to one another
hints of like somebody finds like some
old pictures or something like that
and you're kind of left to fill in the
blanks of these these dudes friendship
uh from that which i think was really
good so wyatt
and christian were best friends you know
when they were kids
and like i said they seemed like they
were both kind of dorky and whatever
now wyatt he seems to have fallen on
some hard times
and you're never entirely sure because
basically he's hanging out
like on the sidewalk with his duffel bag
or whatever
and he's kind of in front of christian's
building
and he makes it seem as though this is
how it seemed to me i'm not sure if
that's
entirely what the implication was but it
seemed to me
that he was just kind of like waiting
there and he wanted to make it seem like
coming across christian was an accident
because
what has happened in wyatt's life was
that i guess he's like he was in
construction or something like that i
think he lived in another state
and he was also engaged to be married
but that also
ended and we're not entirely sure why
although i have some ideas about what
might have happened there but they never
tell you
but uh he's clearly at a time in his
life where maybe he doesn't uh have a
home
so but he doesn't want christian to know
this i guess so he kind of makes it seem
like oh hey i was just in town like
visiting somebody um and they're not
home yet so i was just like waiting for
them to get home and christian was like
oh no man like come up here and we'll
catch up you know because we haven't
seen each other for such a long time
so it so happens that uh wyatt ends up
staying
in christian's apartment with christian
because like i said christian is now by
himself
so through the interaction of these two
characters
you sort of get deeper into their pasts
more christians than wyatt's because
wyatt is very
he's very soft-spoken he's very he's a
little bit
uh socially awkward him and christian
kind of like the way they interact you
can tell that they were once like
you know the closest friends and the
implication i got was that
they were kind of like these dorks or
misfits or something like that in
junior high or high school or whenever
it was and they were kind of like
their only uh each other's only friend
uh because they're very very close and
when they first
when they meet up again at the beginning
of the movie it's really awkward because
they haven't seen each other for a while
but very soon they fall back into
patterns and like doing dorky stuff and
like doing kid type stuff together like
drinking together like
playing uh what's that game that they
call it where they like wrap
up in the [ __ ] uh sleeping bags
blobby wars
and they're kind of like [ __ ] and like
making like geeky references and stuff
so they fall very much back into that
pattern
however wyatt has some
mental issues possibly schizophrenia
uh they never say that outright i mean
he does say that word
but uh and you're led to believe that
that's probably what it is and
the symptoms that he uh shows in this
movie are very much indicative
of schizophrenia he has come to the idea
that the people around him not everybody
but certain people
are demons who look like people
and he believes that he is one of the
blessed
that has been chosen to
fight them to like prevent the end of
the world now he has started getting
this idea because he has a broken cell
phone that he carries around with him
and every now and then he gets a call
on the cell phone and there's like a
creepy voice which is
sometimes the same but sometimes it's
the voice of like other people he
meets like through the course of the
movie so he's kind of bringing them into
his delusion
and he has these voices telling he's
like look the demons are coming
that's not your friend that's not your
brother uh
it's one of them and you have to destroy
them and it's kind of like telling him
all of the stuff that he's gonna have to
do to
prevent the demons from taking over
so the great thing about this is that
this is actually one of the best i think
is one of the best
portrayals of mental illness that i've
seen on film because he doesn't
come across like a crazy person and he
almost kind of comes across
like he knows there's something the
matter with him
he knows but he can't
help it like he can't he's having a hard
time like distinguishing
what's real and what's not and like
sometimes he seems totally fine and
totally lucid
and like i said he really really seems
to have an idea
that other people might not be kosher
with this or you know maybe there's
something the matter with him
or maybe it's just all silly or
something like that so it's really
they portrayed that really really well i
think because i know that there's kind
of a thing where
in a lot of horror movies they do kind
of say it's like oh this person has
schizophrenia or this person's crazy or
whatever
and it's like not portrayed with much uh
sensitivity or
even much realism this one is actually
portrayed
much more like a realistic portrayal
of somebody with that uh mental disorder
um and like i said and he really does
seem aware that he has a mental disorder
but he can't
distinguish fact from fiction and he's
very very frustrated
that he can't so he keeps getting these
phone calls and basically over the
course of the movie he's kind of like
preparing
for the war with the demons that he
thinks that he has to fight
and so you see him going and like buying
a big thing full of like axes and
rope and things and uh then one of the
voices on the phone tells him that uh
demons are susceptible to acid so he
goes and buys like some sulfuric acid
and he pretty much sets up down in uh
like a basement or a storeroom
of christian's house and he's kind of
like
getting ready for the apocalypse down
there there's also something going on
with
christian who like i said is still has
that deep insecurity that he had when he
was a kid
but now it's just trying to mask it you
know by like working out and
you know being dominant and all this
other kind of stuff
um and he has this crush on this uh on
his boss at work whose name is mara
and he um finally gets up the courage to
ask her out they go out the date
doesn't go very well not because of
their fault but because uh something
happens
and he he brings wyatt along and so she
feels obligated to bring another friend
of hers along
the friend like slips on the ice and
breaks her ankle or something like that
so it's just
this big awkward uh you know [ __ ] show
but mara does seem to like christian uh
so they do kind of
you know get a little bit of a romance
thing going there
but then it turns out that mara
has to be the one christian thinks that
he's being like all
dominant and awesome at work and
everything but
when he gets fired and he's the only one
in his department that does get fired
uh he finds a note like on his uh
computer that says you know
way to dominate [ __ ] from everyone so
everyone is just like thinks he's an
obnoxious douche
whereas he thought that he was being all
confident and everything like that
and that really kind of takes the wind
out of his sails also implied that he
has um a little bit of a drinking
problem nobody says it outright
but it does seem like he's drinking a
lot during the course of the movie
and that's another one of his coping
mechanisms so
basically it gets to a point where mara
after
uh she ends up firing christian
obviously they
there's like a little bit of a falling
out there but now it's like super
awkward
but she feels bad so she comes over to
his house and you know they
kind of hang out and then christian
leaves the apartment
and wyatt is still in there with mara um
they've met each other previously
because of like the double date
before and at this point he has gotten
as much remember i mentioned earlier
that sometimes like whoever this
person is that's calling on the cell
phone that sometimes it'll have a
different voice
well prior to mara showing up at the
apartment she has
he has gotten one of these uh wyatt has
gotten one of these phone calls
and it was mara's voice so when mara
comes to the house
he thinks that she is another
chosen person like another blessed
person who knows about the demons
so he takes her down to the basement to
show him to show her like the
preparations
he's making he's like you know i need
help you know what do i do and all this
other stuff and she understandably
flips the [ __ ] out uh because she thinks
that he's going to
flip out and hurt her so after that it's
just like this big whole thing
now i wanted to say that like the best
part of this is the end this is so
okay the whole thing throughout is just
like i said it's it's basically
the heart of it is these two dudes
friendship
and you know mara and there's the other
girl too but she's only like in a scene
or two and i can't even remember what
her name is
but mara is kind of like a big character
as well
throughout the whole thing you're never
really shown
there's not any imagery in it that's
really creepy i mean there's some creepy
creepy imagery but it's like not big
special effect
monster nothing like that it's just
sometimes when you see things through
wyatt's point of view you'll see
something like the person he's talking
to a person and then he'll start hearing
you'll start hearing all this insect
buzzing like a whole bunch of flies
buzzing
and when you hear that you know that he
thinks that this person
is a demon now sometimes that person
just kind of stays looking normal but
sometimes that person starts looking
like because one time he's talking to
mara and her [ __ ]
eyes go like that and like go white and
then like her mouth starts getting
really big and everything's because
you're seeing things from his point of
view
and it's super super creepy so there's
like the best thing about this movie
that makes this movie so creepy is not
so much
like the upsetting imagery even though
some of the imagery is
unsettling but it's just like this sense
of dread that just kind of like pervades
it because you don't know
what wyatt is going to see
and because he's such a good character
and he's a likable character and you
feel bad for him and you empath you
empathize with him a lot
and you empathize with his uh you know
with his friendship this deep friendship
that he has with christian
so you just so it's just like this real
it just kind of pulls your emotions like
in every
direction because it's like you know
that he can't help it
but then on the other hand you know that
he's dangerous and he doesn't want to be
dangerous
he's only dangerous because of what he
believes and he can't help believing
that because he has a mental illness i
mean at one point like he goes up to the
you know roof of uh christian's house
with a nail gun and he's like looking
down like he's gonna shoot people or
then he's gonna do it to himself or
something like that
so it's just this everything is just
like super super tense and you really
really feel
bad for the guy because you know that he
can't help it and he's just
and a lot of times he's just a normal
dude
but he has all of this [ __ ] going on in
his head and
he can't you know help feeling like that
he can't help believing the things he
believes
which like i said um make him dangerous
to everyone around him
because the voices on the phone are
telling him that
you know it could be anybody like any
one of your friends could be a demon
you know even though they look like
they're your friend so the very last
scene
finally wyatt confesses to christian
about
the you know the the demon thing that's
coming
and christian at this point is just kind
of like [ __ ] it because you know he got
fired from his job he's drunk and
everything he's and so he decides
he's kind of going to go along with it
like he's just sort of like okay well
what do we do
you know let me help you with it and
there's a great scene because at first
they're going to like run off they're
going to go somewhere
and then that doesn't work out and then
so he takes
christian down to the basement and he's
like you know this is where i've been
preparing for the war or whatever
he's like and i'm not sure if you're one
of them and so christian
[ __ ] i love this he says well if
you're not sure
that i'm a demon then you got to tie me
up
and so wyatt is just kind of like okay
so he ties him up he puts tape over his
mouth he puts a bag over his head
because he's had this idea from like the
phone
conversations that the armageddon or
whatever like all the demons are going
to take over
um at a certain time like at 6 00 p.m or
whatever like and he had to
hear three peels of thunder or something
like that and that happens
so he's just kind of like okay well
now's the time
the final scene is just so so great
because it's just so tense the lights go
out
and it's just like christian is sitting
there in the chair
tied up with a bag overs he can't see
anything and he can't
talk and wyatt is just standing there
like with the acid
just kind of like that like hoping that
it's not a demon and he can see
like in his mind he's seeing like
weird shapes like moving under the bag
as though
christian is transforming and in the end
like i said i am going to spoil the end
so
don't be mad at me i told you this a
long time ago in the end he almost pours
it he almost pours it because he just
can't and it keeps he sees the shapes in
the bag and he's just like oh [ __ ] and
he sees all this other kind of stuff
and then in the end he doesn't pour it
he decides he's going to trust
his friend over his hallucinations which
he doesn't know are hallucinations
when he takes the bag off christian is
normal
and that seems like it's almost kind of
i don't say
you know it obviously doesn't cure his
schizophrenia but
it sort of like startles him out of his
illusion and the fact that christian
trusted wyatt enough knowing that wyatt
believed he might be a demon knowing
that he might kill him
but the fact that that christian was
actually willing to just sit there and
almost get killed and maybe possibly get
killed
to try and show that he wasn't a demon
was just a great [ __ ] it was just i
just loved the ending of this so much
because it's just i really loved
the fact that you could see the depth of
these two guys
friendship that they trusted each other
to that extent and just the fact that
christian did that
and it was good for him too because he
was kind of like
he made a crack earlier on that he was
gonna after he got fired he's like i'm
going to join the army because
i always felt like if somebody pointed a
gun at my face or if i was going to die
i would just like piss my pants and i
want to get over that
and so the fact that he sat there and he
could have died
because wyatt could very well have
killed him and he almost did kind of got
him over his fear and like made him more
confident as well
i just love this movie so much i just
think it's it just goes to show
what somebody with a vision can do
with like very little money and just
like a few characters
if you have a good story like this if
you have these actors who are just
willing to commit and like i said their
relationships are just so
natural and i really really liked that
this really had
a really big heart to it i mean the the
two guys friendship i think
even if it hadn't been even if there
hadn't been like creepy
you know kind of imagery in it i would
have watched a movie just about
their friendship just because it was
just so genuine
and so heartfelt and in turn
that made the creepy stuff way creepier
because like i said you
you understood that that's the way he
was seeing the world and he couldn't
help it but it was making him dangerous
to everybody that
loved him and that was like really
tragic but then i really really liked
that the ending was
uplifting now it's weird because i've
seen some reviews of this where people
said
well they leave it ambiguous as to
whether
why it was right maybe people you know
maybe it was like invasion of the body
snatchers and like demons or aliens or
whatever really were taking people over
so he was right about it
i don't know if i i guess i can see that
but i'm pretty sure
that at the end like that end scene i'm
pretty sure they were implying
that he was schizophrenic and was just
seeing the world like that i don't think
that
it was meant to imply that the demons
were real or what he was saying
uh seeing was real um i guess you could
read it that way if you wanted to but i
did not get that impression just because
of a few things that happened like
during the last scene because
you know some of the things that he saw
like you know when he kind of snapped
out of it later like weren't
really there so i definitely think that
they were implying that it was his
mental illness that i don't think that
i don't think there was any real demons
or anything but you know like i said if
you want to read it that way you totally
can
but yeah this was again just a really
really great
creepy unsettling like psychological
horror that had a really lot of heart to
it which you don't see in a lot of
horror movies
so i definitely definitely recommend it
if that sounds like your kind of thing
occasion i hope some people will be like
oh it's not a horror movie oh it's too
slow blah blah blah
i know there's that whole thing but if
this kind of thing is your cup of tea
and you haven't seen it because i don't
really see a ton of people talking about
it
um flew a little bit under the under the
radar unfortunately because it's really
really good
um but yeah it's on 2b now uh for free
if you want to watch it i believe it's
also on amazon prime
if you want to watch it on there i'm not
sure if it's on netflix anymore it used
to be
but at least in the us i don't think it
is i would definitely recommend it it's
a great
psychological thriller and it's just as
i said one of one of the best
depictions the most sensitive depictions
of uh mental illness i think i've ever
seen in in the fact that they don't
demonize it or they don't make him seem
like a crazy
person you know what i mean they really
like threaded that needle uh very well i
thought
uh perry blackshear has gone on this was
actually his first movie amazingly
uh he's gone on to make a couple more i
think there's one called the siren
which i keep seeing i keep seeing it on
like amazon prime or something like that
and i didn't realize that it was the
same guy that had done it so i'm
definitely gonna have to watch that one
eventually as well but yeah i definitely
check this one out
and uh i will see you guys on the next
one bye